how long have you lived here I lived in
this city I bought in this city since I
born until now I grew up in this town
there are a lot of people that have
anger towards Israel hate towards Israel
I will give you example
like if someone come to fight your
family and to enter your home you will
stand closing your hand if someone
killed your brother killed your father
you will be easy it will be as as super
crazy
this is what's happened with Palestinian
a lot of Palestine was killed for no
reason what gives you hope about the
future
the situation is getting worse and worse
and worse today they close all over
around Batman because there's something
happen there's a fight between Boston as
well and if you go all over around the
city all the entrance of the city it's a
close second thing I want to leave
something I don't like politics so much
because you know in the end we are all
human doesn't matter if you are a
Palestinian or Israeli or Russian or
American doesn't matter what your
religious Christian Muslim you and then
well we are all of him what we want we
want just peace we want to live in peace
we don't want any more fight we want to
have our freedom to go wherever we want
and that's it